when Tim Cook the head of Apple decided
to come out of the closet and to to
openly be gay he turned to you and said
I really admired the way you handled
that aspect of your life and asked you
for advice called you and asked you for
advice in the corporate world
it is so frowned upon to be there's so
few openly gay CEOs of companies they
are so paralyzed still to this day
admitting that they're gay that they
don't do it and when Tim Cook I don't
know the man but when he decided to come
out to me it was probably one of the
most important statements that could be
made he's a remarkable guy and and I
think you're look you're right he's
operating you know a global I mean we
all know you know how incredible Apple
is but he's operating you know this
global business with global impact and
you know in all countries and so you
know there's a lot of things to think
through and and you know I'm sure it was
I mean I know you know it's obviously a
difficult thing when somebody's in a
position like that do you think he was
calling you to say do you think this is
wise if I do it or was he looking for
specifics on like how do I do this
what's the classiest best way I can do
this
what was he looking for in that
conversation I think he knew what he
wanted to do he just and he had done he
had looked at how he wanted to do it and
how other people had done it and I think
he sort of liked the approach I took
which was to write something and to kind
of explain stuff and not make it a try
to make it a you know it's not you know
looking to be on the maggot on a cover
of a magazine you just want to get your
you know say something and explain why
you haven't said something and why you
are saying something and sort of you
know add your voice to the to the stream
of you know that you hope is moving in
the right direction
you